[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Francia defiende su título Al domingo
dos hombres que empezaron el mundial
como suplentes Teo Hernández y colomonín
fueron los autores de los goles con los
que el campeón vigente líquido a
Marruecos en semifinales
la alegría se desborda en Francia y el
orgullo por La hazaña prevalece en
Marruecos a pesar de la derrota vamos a
Aparicio marrakech para vivir el
resultado en todos los frentes
Argentina espera Francia en la final En
búsqueda de un próximo tricampeón
mundial La magia de Messi contra la
velocidad de mbappean adelantamos el
análisis
y para analizar el desarrollo de cada
jornada contamos como siempre con la
presencia de Octavio sazo periodista de
la emisora Blu radio en Colombia Octavio
un placer tenerlo acá Hola Omar un gusto
saludarte como siempre y aprovechamos
también para darle la bienvenida al
enviado especial de France 24 nuestro
compañero Juan pupiales quien está en
Qatar actualizándonos el día a día de
este mundial saludos Juan
Octavio un placer estar con ustedes de
nuevo ya en esta recta final de este
mundial de Qatar 2022
y Francia está en la final la victoria
dos cero sobre Marruecos en semifinales
deja Los Galos como los primeros
campeones Defensores que llegan a la
instancia decisiva desde 1998 cuando lo
hizo Brasil la ambición va más allá
convertirse en los primeros bicampeones
en años consecutivos en 60 años desde
Chile 62 antes de ir a Qatar para
revivir el partido con nuestro enviado
especial nos vamos a París donde Erika
olavarría periodista de France 24 nos
cuenta cómo se ha vivido este encuentro
Saludos Erika
Hola Omar buenas noches Voy a tratar de
hacer este directo pues estoy rodeada
con ustedes pueden ver de la hinchada no
solo marroquí sino que de todo el
mcgrego Argelia presente también porque
aunque en un primer momento los
marroquíes estaban muy tristes de esta
derrota ellos estaban seguros de hacer
historia llegar a la final de un mundial
finalmente la fiesta ha continuado aquí
sobre todo porque hay mucho marroquíes
que también son franceses ha habido un
reconocimiento también de los marroquíes
al trabajo hecho por Francia y viceversa
de los franceses A este logro histórico
de los marroquíes escuchemos lo que nos
dijeron un poco más temprano
fue un bello partido ambos equipos
jugaron muy bien los marroquíes jugaron
muy bien pero nosotros De todas formas
logramos ganar felicitaciones a ambos Y
qué más puedo decir estamos en la final
Francia estuvo muy muy sólida en el
primer tiempo nos ganaron desde el punto
de vista táctico
y en el segundo no logramos concretar
nuestras oportunidades entonces un
aplauso a Francia y nosotros
disputaremos una pequeña final contra
Croacia el sábado
Erika de alguna manera
se temía o había había temores de que
pudiera haber algún tema de seguridad
ahí que hiciera preocupar Cómo se manejó
este aspecto estuvo digamos Todo
tranquilo durante el partido
efectivamente Omar estábamos
impresionados recordemos que había un
amplio dispositivo de seguridad Diez mil
policías y gendarmes desplegados en toda
Francia la mitad en la región de París
ildefons y un cuarto de ellos solamente
en la ciudad de París el sábado pasado
cuando Francia marco se clasificaron
hubo veinte mil personas en los campos
elíseos pero hasta ahora todo es
tranquilo como ustedes pueden ver
incluso los marroquíes siguen celebrando
aún cuando ya no están en esa final
le damos las gracias
le damos las gracias Erika y le
invitamos a que nos acompañe a Marruecos
porque más temprano nos reportó desde
marrakech la corresponsal Sofía catalá y
esto nos dijo sobre la forma en que los
aficionados han vivido esta semifinal
histórica para los Leones del Atlas
sí Bueno finalmente Los Leones del Atlas
no han conseguido vencer a la selección
de Francia en este partido de
semifinales un partido que Francia
dominó pues prácticamente en todo
momento de hecho el primer gol de Teo
Hernández llegó en los primeros cinco
minutos el segundo en la segunda parte
Aquí estaba todo el mundo muy nervioso
muy tenso pero finalmente no pudo ser y
hasta aquí llega a Marruecos en este
mundial en un mundial en el que Cabe
destacar que han hecho historia y es que
esta ha sido la primera vez que la
selecciona de Marruecos llega en la
historia a las semifinales y también Esa
es la primera vez en la historia Pues
que una selección de un país que es
árabe hamagic y africano consigue llegar
a esta fase del mundial aquí en
Marruecos la verdad es que todo el mundo
se ha volcado desde el primer momento
con la selección el fútbol ha conseguido
de nuevo unir a todo el país y todo el
mundo la verdad es que estaba muy
ilusionado al final pues la victoria no
ha podido ser Y bueno pues Los
Seguidores de los leones de la tasa
abandonan este mundial se despiden de él
sin haber podido llegar a la final pero
se van muy atentos con mucha felicidad y
con mucho orgullo de saber que tienen el
mejor equipo de todos esos tiempos de
casi lo han demostrado en todos los
duelos hasta día de hoy también se va se
van muy contentos de aquí pues por saber
que han conseguido hacer historia y
puede Marruecos seguir haciendo historia
y ahora sí nos vamos a acatar con el
enviado especial de France 24 Juan
pupiales para el repaso de esta segunda
y última jornada de semifinales Juan qué
lectura le deja este partido de hoy
fue un partido que se rompió mucho
respecto al libreto que cualquiera de
nosotros podría haber tenido pensado Y
es que ese gol tempranero de Francia al
minuto 5 cambió todo para el conjunto
galo y también para el equipo de
Marruecos Marruecos que se enfrentó ante
un escenario en el que no se había visto
en esta copa mundo estaban con el
marcador en contra ya no podían haber
hecho como hicieron contra otros equipos
contra Portugal contra España de
defender de tener esa defensa férrea y
esperar para salir a atacar esta vez era
la presión la que estaba sobre ellos
sobre el equipo de Marruecos para salir
a buscar el partido Francia manejó muy
bien eso durante la primera parte del
combinado de Jackson que sin duda alguna
pudo haber tenido ocasiones para Haber
puesto ese 2 a 0 aprovechando los
espacios que empezaron a aparecer ya
ante esa urgencia de Marruecos para la
segunda parte ese equipo de Francia ese
equipo de Marruecos Perdón que se volcó
por completo para el ataque Y eso
Francia lo supo manejar muy bien también
y desde sham que ya había dicho en
previa de Francia mientras aquí tenemos
de Francia y de Marruecos por favor
compártenos dos colores es una fiesta
esto les decía que para la segunda parte
desde shampoo puedo gestionar muy bien
esa urgencia que tenía Marruecos de
atacar Marruecos que se volcó por
completo para el ataque y diría lo que
hizo fue retirar por ejemplo a hombres
como Olivia
para buscar más atacar por las bandas al
final el premio llegó un poco de manera
tardía lo hizo con ese gol de moani para
poner el 2 a 0 partido además que fue
muy accidentado para Marruecos ayer su
defensa estrella o uno de sus defensas
estrellas que estuvo como titular en la
primera alineación titular que nos
entregaron a nosotros y que finalmente
se lesionó del calentamiento y no pudo
estar en este encuentro a los 20 minutos
y lesiona sais un poco no salió para
nada hoy en este partido ese guión que
tenía previsto el seleccionador wallet
regreggy y djm que supo jugar muy bien
con sus cartas incluso también afectado
por las bajas la de Adrián rabio y la de
de entraron fofana y entró también con
ataque cumplieron de buena manera en
este encuentro Juan y hablando de de
sustituciones a Marruecos le ha tocado a
Francia le ha tocado sustituir nombres
que que parecían insustituibles como el
caso de Benzema de canté de Pogba y
luego ya una vez hecha la convocatoria
también quinpe o Lucas Hernández que se
lesionó en pleno mundial se puede decir
que le han respondido los nuevos
convocados o los nuevos nombres que se
suman en la convocatoria de The champs
que han rendido efectivamente jugadores
como el propio Teo Hernández que vio
como tuvo que reemplazar a su hermano
Lucas Hernández al comienzo de esta copa
mundo un jugador que hace cuatro años
era jugador de la Real Sociedad no
estuvo en la convocatoria de Rusia 2018
y yo como su hermano se proclamaba
campeón del mundo ahora teó Hernández
hoy marcó ese primer tanto para el
encuentro en ese partido en el que entró
a reemplazar a su hermano dio una
asistencia sin duda alguna el mejor
lateral Zurdo para mí que tenemos en
este mundial otros jugadores que han
brillado con luz propia y que tenían una
losa muy grande encima choamení que
llegaba aquí con ese peso de reemplazar
a cantea Pogba ocho America tuvo la
primera mejor primera parte que yo he
visto un centrocampista en esta copa
mundo han cumplido los centrales
sudamericanos y conaté han cumplido
Jules que le quitó la posición a
benjamán para bajen en el lateral
derecho cuder que venía con muchas dudas
con el Barcelona y se alzado muy bien en
esa posición de lateral derecho y se ha
afianzado en una muy buena que ha
encajado muchos goles hoy fue por cierto
el primer partido en el que Francia no
encajó tantos en esta copa mundo de
Qatar pero en líneas generales han
entregado un buen papel destacar incluso
obviamente lo de colon moani que hoy
jugó su segundo partido en este mundial
y en la primera pelota que tocó puse dos
a cero para Francia frente a los
marroquíes primer gol con la camiseta de
Francia para el delantero del Frankfurt
Octavio hoy estuvieron ausentes dos
hombres que que se habían convertido en
puntales particularmente el caso de
upamecano en la defensa rabiot tampoco
pudo estar Cómo qué tanto pesaron esa
falta en el equipo Cómo se vio Francia
sin estos hombres en en cancha Sí yo
creo que la la ausencia más fuerte que
tuvo Francia hoy fue la de rabiot porque
el equipo se vio digamos limitado en ese
en ese sector de la cancha no se le vio
el ritmo acostumbrado en esta Copa del
Mundo Incluso se pareció más al equipo
que perdió con túnez que a los equipos
que han ido ganando a lo largo del
mundial rabiot A pesar de todas las
críticas y de todo lo que se hablaba
sobre él antes del inicio de la copa del
mundo y que incluso estuvo a punto de
salir de la Juventus porque no rendía
hoy es un jugador fundamental para el
equipo de líder de James y todas las
pelotas de la mitad de la cancha pasan
por él es el es el vínculo entre
griezmann y los delanteros y es el
jugador más importante en ese sector del
terreno entonces hoy se notó en Francia
con poco ritmo con poco juego en función
de eso y me parece que fue mucho más
importante la ausencia de raviol que la
dupamecano que seguramente si está mejor
va a jugar la final de la de la copa del
mundo pero que rabión no tiene sustituto
Y en este equipo Más allá de las
apariciones de los jugadores jóvenes en
la mitad de la cancha
y volvemos con Juan porque hoy vimos un
Marruecos con menos capacidad de
respuesta que el equipo que eliminó a
Bélgica a España a Portugal podemos
decir que el cansancio pasó factura en
las filas de Marruecos
sin duda alguna regrágil lo había negado
en la rueda de prensa El seleccionador
de Marruecos que dijo que no se puede
estar cansado en una semifinal de un
mundial Si hoy sí quedó demostrado que
la fatiga puede hacer presencia en un
partido tan importante como este no
vimos al mismo Sofía Man rabas en el
centro del campo no vimos el mismo
prácticamente pasó desapercibido en este
partido se notó la fatiga que
arrastraron los jugadores de Marruecos
particularmente casos como el de hakimi
jugadores que han brillado con luz
propia en esta copa mundo se notó que es
un equipo que viene con unas molestias
importantes el propio regragi había
dicho ayer que tenía varios lesionados
ni siquiera se atrevió a dar una cifra
exacta de cuántos jugadores venían con
molestias ya en el partido contra
Portugal tuvo que empezar a retirar de
manera anticipada algunos titulares para
tener que ir empezar a darles aire y se
notó sin duda alguna que esa fatiga que
ese cansancio si le pagó si le pasó
factura a este equipo africano que igual
debe estar muy orgulloso porque lo que
ha hecho no no lo he conseguido ningún
otro equipo africano ni árabe en la
historia de un mundial
Octavio ya hablando del legado que esta
actuación histórica deja para Marruecos
este país se ha estado proponiendo para
organizar un campeonato mundial de
fútbol queda un poco más cerca después
de esta hazaña Claro claro
indudablemente porque cuando normalmente
salvo la excepción de de Qatar cuando
FIFA empieza a investigar o presenta
digamos el libro de cargos para que los
países puedan postularse a la Copa del
Mundo incluye además que su fútbol que
su selección tenga la capacidad de jugar
en cierto nivel
exactamente
la única selección local que no ha
podido incluso marcar un gol en esta en
esta copa del mundo pero más allá de eso
Marruecos empieza a confirmar no solo
que es la selección africana de mayor
impacto en la historia de los mundiales
la selección árabe que que mejora ha
estado una copa del mundo va por quedar
en el tercer lugar que eso también va va
a tener una digamos un un tema muy
interesante Más allá de lo conseguido en
algún momento por por Turquía en una
copa del mundo cuando cuando le quitó
ese puesto a Corea del Sur pero el caso
es que Marruecos empieza a movilizar un
montón de cosas que pueden generar eso a
su favor y evidentemente cuando
Marruecos si llega a hacerlo se presenta
para sostener una copa del mundo va a
tener esa carta de de fondo no diciendo
bueno nosotros primero jugamos muy bien
al fútbol logramos muy buenos resultados
y luego Además nos acompañó un montón de
gente en todos lados eso realmente es
una carta Pero luego está el tema
económico y evidentemente más allá de
eso habrá que ver cómo cómo se van
actualizando los mundiales de a quién
más
bien y el domingo se define un nuevo
tricampeón Francia Busca una tercera
Corona después de 1998 y 2018 y
Argentina quiere sumar una a las que ya
se alcanzaron en 1978 y
1986 primero a Juan le pregunto qué
espera usted de esa final Francia
Argentina
es una final en la que espero que dos de
los mejores equipos sin duda alguna que
hemos visto en este mundial se enfrente
con cara a caras muy interesantes ver
por ejemplo ese Duelo obviamente de
Messi contra mbappeo de griezmann contra
Messi Por decirlo así ver esos duelos
también obviamente de la esa buena
defensa de Argentina frente a ese
poderío y que ha tenido a Francia en el
ataque sin duda algunas enfrentan dos
equipos que han dejado un muy buen papel
colectivo en esta copa mundo tanto
Francia como Argentina han sabido
Mostrar que son muy completos
prácticamente en todas las líneas Hugo
llovi ha respondido cuando ha tenido que
hacerlo en un partido contra Inglaterra
el Diego Martínez respondió en esa tanda
de penaltis para avanzar a semifinales
el centro de campo de Argentina que ha
tenido momentos muy buenos es muy bueno
el mundial que está haciendo Enzo
Fernández lo decía previamente es muy
bueno el mundial También que está
haciendo
alguna Messi el mejor en este papel con
Argentina ahora acompañado con Julián
Álvarez en el caso de Francia Tenemos
que hablar obviamente ese papel que se
ha consagrado en este mundial como el
mayor goleador en la historia de la
selección de Francia acompañado de un
griezmann que se lleva todos los elogios
de su compañero que destacan aquí ese
papel que tiene más de armador más de
organizador un poco más y que
sigue demostrando una explosión de nivel
futbolístico son varios los jugadores de
ambas selecciones que están aquí
alcanzando su nivel máximo por ejemplo
el caso de nahuel Molina también con
Argentina que está demostrando un buen
nivel para mí algunas deudas la con
Francia la de usman dembélé que creo que
está muy lejos del nivel de sus
compañeros y con Argentina creo que ha
sido algo irregular lo de Rodrigo de
Paul Así que jugadores cada uno de ellos
que han tenido todo un camino muy largo
en esta copa mundo y que vamos a ver ese
esa final Como Define Quién será el
campeón
y usted Octavio dónde piensa que puede
estar el punto de inflexión hacia uno u
otro lado bueno es la final deseada por
el Emir de Qatar además Porque además
tiene a Messi y a mbappé las dos joyas
del psg creo que es la final que que
prácticamente el mundo entero en cuanto
al tema de pronósticos y demás deseaban
yo creo que la clave de este partido
puede pasar por un par de detalles uno
de ellos Argentina va a tener un día más
de descanso en función de su rival
Argentina va a recuperar seguramente
para el domingo Ángel Di María y a el
huevo Acuña que son dos jugadores
fundamentales para este equipo de María
que no ha jugado prácticamente luego de
de su lesión y habrá que ver cómo llega
a Francia si llega con rabiot y
upamecano porque si no es una cierta
ventaja la que da el equipo galo en ese
sector de la cancha frente a un rival
que no le dará concesiones como si le
dio en su momento Marruecos Entonces
ahora que ver cómo llega Por un lado
está toda la motivación de Messi y
compañía que saben que es su última
oportunidad la última oportunidad de
Messi y por el otro lado la juventud la
potencia y el gol de un jugador como
kilian mbappé entonces va a ser
extraordinario Marvel el futuro contra
el pasado no contra contra el rey que va
a dejar su corona que seguramente se la
va a dejar puesta aquí en mbappé pase lo
que pase bien y Juan no crea que se
libra de nosotros Porque no hay fútbol
mañana nos reencontramos acá en diario
El Mundial
igual placer Así será que bonito
disfrutar de esos últimos días de esta
copa mundo
igual usted Octavio El compromiso es
también con usted para mañana mañana nos
reencontramos con mucho gusto y nosotros
cerramos con una invitación a que
continúe con la programación de France
24 y que nos acompaña el nuevo mañana en
diario El Mundial
[Música]